after 13 years millions of dollars in
legal fees and countless court dates it
is finally d-day in the britney spears
conservative ship case lauren zema is at
the courthouse in downtown l.a with the
latest
it just happened britney spears finally
free the crowd outside the courthouse
erupting after the news was revealed
judge brenda penny saying this
conservatorship is no longer required it
is terminated britney tweeted calling it
the best day ever and brittany's
attorney matthew rosengart spoke to
reporters right after what's next for
brittany is up to one person
brittany
i'm so proud of her
i thank her i thank her for her
courage
and poise
and power
and last night britney looked ready to
celebrate this outcome her fiance sam
askari posting this video of the two
dancing and matching free britney
t-shirts brittany writing earlier that
she hadn't prayed for something more in
my life
i deserve to have the same rights as
anybody does by having a child a family
so how much could this ruling really
change things this morning i spoke with
tamar armanik who represents amanda
bynes's mother in her daughter's
conservatorship
what kind of freedoms will she now have
the same freedoms that you and i enjoy
every single day brittany posted this
week that donatella versace is already
working on her wedding dress britney can
go get a marriage license this afternoon
and actually go get married tomorrow she
will be able to deal with birth control
issues and if she does want to move
forward and have more children she will
be able to that is her decision
[Music]